magical flying cameras may make for
great weapons in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but according to Chris
Hemsworth's wife
they don't make four crates house decor
most actors like to take home a piece of
memorabilia from the sets of their films
like small props are a piece of clothing
to remind them of a special time in
their life or an important character
they played if you're the god of thunder
however your eyes are firmly affixed to
your faithful hammer Mjolnir
meeow meeow what me Anya Thor whom
Hemsworth has played in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe since the release of
well for in 2011 is known to wield
Mjolnir at all times in combat making
frequent use of a deadly swing that
could not even the Hulk out of his boots
if the Green Monster wore any of course
the enchanted weapon is certainly proven
useful on-screen for both combats and
for just getting around and Hemsworth
has apparently taken a huge liking to it
in real life bringing several of the
prop hammers home with him after
wrapping films on the MCU
well the Aussie actor loves having them
around his wife model and actress Elsa
Pataky
has reached her limit on the prop in
their home so much so that she's imposed
a strict rule Hemsworth absolutely has
to quit swiping hammers from Seth
speaking on the Australian radio show
fitzy and whipper attackee shared that
her husband a snatched not just one prop
Mjolnir how many how much do you have
there five five now don't get us wrong
me owner is the epic weapon to wield but
that's an awful lot of hammers for
people in the house to trip over
especially considering you know some
mere mortal can't just lift it up and
move it over a few inches unless they're
also wielding America's ass that is yeah
you know we're talking about jokes aside
Pataki also explained that she and
Hemsworth of regular arguments about
where the props are and aren't allowed
to go in the house she dished he always
picks the best places in the house and
I'm like it's not going there we have
five of them like seriously no of course
Thord wants his trusty Mjolnir close at
hand at all times so Hemsworth wants to
make sure the hammers are prominently
displayed all over the couple's
Australian home in case of emergency or
maybe in case he needs a last-minute
gift remind us which year is he
enchanted Asgardian hammer anniversary
we also can't imagine Pataki would have
been any happier if a husband brought
home Thor's second weapon Stormbreaker
the giant battle ax Thor helps Forge
after his sister Hallett
me or Nia in thor ragnarok is just a tad
bigger than the hammer so here's hoping
Pataki hasn't had to find a space for
this significantly larger weapon in the
house unfortunately for Pataki the flow
of hammers isn't likely to stop flowing
anytime soon
despite her ban Hemsworth is set to
appear as soar again in Thor love and
thunder which is set for release in
November 2021
they Pataki has put a foot down and
wants him not to bring more hammers home
Hemsworth seems like the cheeky type you
might want just one extra prob and
Pataki just might have to find space for
more of a husband's very unique brand of
decor Thor love and thunder will see a
new hero rise up to take the mantle and
powers of Thor the God of Thunder former
love interest Jane Foster played by
Natalie Portman is set to make a return
to the MCU after seemingly quitting for
good following 2013's Thor the dark
world in the upcoming flick fans will
get to see jane wield Mjolnir when she
becomes the mighty thor
hopefully for Potocki Portman will be
the one taking the hammer home this time
around check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and to the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]